un combat de tous les instants des
actions de grande classe ce dimanche 7
octobre la rencontre entre les bleus et
verts du sky rugby et vitry a tenu
toutes ses promesses
après une première période convaincante
ponctuée par deux essais les saint
quentinois amène logiquement à la
mi-temps à 15 à 3 on fait une première
mi temps
bonn en à leur encontre on doit on doit
plutôt attendre la mi temps se dire que
il faut courber le dos un petit peu et
au contraire c'est nous qui prenons en
main on retour des vestiaires vitré
montre un autre visage et revient à 15
partout sur cet essai le match se durcit
sur cette action à la dernière seconde
les visiteurs arrache la victoire au
bout du suspense
score final 22 18 sentiment c'est que on
a bien maîtrisé match on a pris les
devants et et on a attendu que ça
finisse en fait on a subi un peu la fin
et résultat bat caen attend on attend la
bo défend de la ligne à mon dos et ça
finit chez doigt après cette défaite le
sky rugby abandonne sa place de leader
de division honneur et pointe à la
deuxième place avec la aujourd'hui
mentalement ça fait très mal parce que
c'est notre premier match à domicile on
se disait que ne boudez klaus allait
être imprenable cette saison quoi et
puis en plus avec deux victoires acteurs
pour commencer on s'était mis dans de
bonnes conditions pour accueillir une
équipe comme vitry malheureusement ce
match mais un petit coup derrière la
tête prochain match pour les joueurs du
sky rugby ce dimanche 14 octobre sur le
terrain de vincennes pour le choc de
cette poule de division honneur
entre le deuxième et le troisième du
championnat